here at cbs news we're honoring some of
the many front line heroes
helping america get through this
pandemic not only the doctors and the
nurses but also the teachers and the
delivery drivers
and so many more people were calling
this segment my frontline hero
because it's based on your submissions
from all around the country
here are just some of those stories
[Music]
my name is mike tavela and my frontline
hero is my fiancee melissa
[Music]
she's a fifth grade teacher at gardner's
avenue elementary school in levittown
new york
ever since the start of this pandemic
she's really done even more than i
thought was humanly possible
she never fails to provide 110 to her
students we were supposed to get married
this past july but
her selflessness never ceases to amaze
me she's still with all this going on is
able to dedicate herself fully to her
students
as a fellow teacher i can only hope that
i'm as inspirational to my students as
she is to me
hi my name is benny and my frontline
hero is my fiance jerry
who works for ups and i hear
very amazing stories from jerry
delivering to different people and how
he
helps them and just takes the time to
listen to them
and talk to them and just get friendly
with them and that makes me feel good
because
this is the man i love and i just know
how
he is towards us and it makes me feel
nice
that all these people feel the same way
i do about him
hi my name is joy smith and my front
line hero is my son
evan w smith the
owner and founder of evan w smith
funeral services located in delaware
he and his colleagues were experiencing
the very same issues
of other frontline workers the fear of
being exposed to
the coronavirus the fear of exposing
their families
if you feel lost or alone we're here to
listen to you
one thing never changed providing each
family he encounters with compassion
i am so immensely proud of you
hi i'm barb t from minnesota you can do
it ryan can't you
our frontline hero is sandy sanders
ryan's art teacher the pandemic has had
a real
impact on people with special needs and
trying to
process what's going on in the world and
through art
and through sandy and zoom rob has
learned
a better way to cope with feelings of
being so isolated during the pandemic
my name is riley kraft and i am 10 years
old and my frontline
heroes is my mom susie craft and my
father chris craft
my parents on a meat locker and
they are my frontline heroes because
they've done so much during the pandemic
oh it wasn't an option to close not in
our eyes anyways he's got a whole crew
of people down there that
rely on him they work their butts off
and it's hard work i mean they're
pulling thousand pound beef you know and
and they don't complain
i don't know how he does it it's been
non-stop since march that's what rural
iowa is about
it's rough work and he gets up and does
it every day and doesn't complain my
name is mandy
i'm from sapulp oklahoma and my
frontline hero is my mother-in-law
vivian
vivian is 71 years old she's diabetic
she has asthma
and then five years ago became a single
parent to her great great nieces
[Music]
any of these things could have prevented
her from working her cashier job on the
front lines
during this pandemic but it hasn't my
husband and i voiced our concerns to her
regarding her working on the front lines
her response was i have the girls to
think of
so she's definitely an inspiration for
myself and everybody that knows her
i'm not hero i'm doing what everybody
else would do i'm doing what
thousands of people around this country
does
you do what you have to do but i'm not a
hero but i love you mandy
and vince and mackenzie and the kids
wow boy that's a tough choice there you
know you know you're in a
at-risk category but you've got to be
the provider and that late in life as
well
yeah it's reminded the simple things you
know the stuff that we take for granted
every single day
where you see people are doing it you
know without complaint
without seeking any kind of recognition
they're doing it because they want to
and because they think they
have to and they have a duty what i love
in there was in so many cases you saw
family members paying respect to other
family members
that's the best part and really seeing
you know
something that you know really special i
don't think there's anything better than
a mother saying and vice versa i'm proud
of you
yeah to make your family members proud
is something everybody wants
everybody also nothing better than a
good butcher and we saw one of those
that's true i love a good burger tony
you're right